do one
welcome everybody
uh
everybody out
on the internet
wherever you may be listening to this
on youtube
twitter
elsewhere are as a podcast on the into
the impossible podcast network
uh welcome to you and to my friend
professor garrett lewis let me just make
sure we are live and being heard
we are being live we are being heard
there's a few of us there a bunch of
nerds my friends my
fellow
colleagues and travelers and there's no
one i'd rather get into this controversy
with as our guest might say than the new
guarant uh who's phenomenal thinker a
uh esteemed colleague and an eminent
cosmologist and i'm just delighted that
you could join us to talk about these
controversies as you know i talk quite
frequently about the orthodox but also
some of the unorthodox things in
cosmology so first i want to ask you
what's life like on friday the uh the
2nd of september down under
oh it's pretty good spring is arriving
uh it's warming up it's looking very
nice outside
ah fantastic yes and what are the
lottery numbers i should be playing on
friday
ah unfortunately
it doesn't work
it doesn't work that way unfortunately
well it's a delight to have you here and
i thought we'd get right into it and uh
talk about this this uh you know
so-called alleged
crisis and uh panic that's taken over
our field i don't know if you are
suffering from the panic
all the way down under but
but up here in the us at least it made
quite a splash i've been
quoted in several different venues and
and
one of the reasons i enjoy speaking with
you is i think that you're
a sober voice of reason who like me uh
doesn't shy away from controversy and
likes to uh use it as a teachable moment
both for
professionals but also for the
non-professionals the lay audience that
we serve by virtue of our outreach and
you've written so many wonderful books
and we had you on just this past uh
season
for your most recent book about the
university of the universe come from
i've got that my bookshelf here um and
previously you wrote a book with uh luke
barnes
about the
steps that one would need to take in
order to overthrow the big bang and the
title of that book was the cosmic
revolutionaries handbook and i think
that's a spectacular book for many
reasons the content is phenomenal but
also the kind of rubric that one must
apply when assessing claims either in
support of or in claimed refutation of
an existing paradigm so i want to ask
you i don't know if i asked you that
when in the interview that you and luke
did uh it's almost two years ago now i
can't believe it uh but um can you
summarize why did you write that book
the cosmic revolutionaries handbook what
was the purpose behind that book
oh well luke and i do an awful lot of
outreach we also you know um interact
with people
through various media and
there's often you
somebody in the crowd who has a new idea
about the universe so they've heard
about the big bang and there's aspects
of it that they don't like
and so they've got their new theory
their new idea their new hypothesis
and we found ourselves repeating
ourselves over and over again about
right that's a nice idea but what does
it predict how does it deal with this
issue and that issue and how is it
better than the current big bang picture
that we have
and of course the people with their
ideas they hadn't got past that first
thing of i've got my idea
so we decided that we would get
all this down and sort of lay out the
plan of what it is you really need to do
if you want to overturn cosmology so
that it was essentially to have
something to point to to say oh this is
what your idea should do but also to get
the process of science out there into
the broader audience because i think
there's a lot of cosmology books on the
market
but not a lot of them talk about the
process by which that those cosmological
ideas
turn into you know
our understanding of the universe around
us so we wanted to make it less of a
look this is cosmology and more of a
this is how you do cosmology kind of
book
yes
and i think what's so spectacular about
that book as well as your other books is
that you're not dismissive you know some
of the our colleagues on twitter have
been less than kind uh to mr lerner uh
and uh accused the cosmological
community of furthering this censorship
and the suppression of heresy and ad
hominem attacks and some did call him
names and i've refused to do that um and
we're not going to comment on his uh on
his other projects which involve the
quest for fusion etc except to say when
necessary what the relevance or
irrelevance is
of the cosmological model that he's
proffering towards the um the
establishment of cheap clean energy on
earth which is of course a noble goal
but i think the conflation of ideas
bears some scrutiny although it won't be
the dominant portion of our conversation
and we might take questions um online
even if uh
i assume eric will be watching if not
listening he sent me an email
asking me to take a look at his most
recent video
which claims to refute some of the
claims that i made that dr becky made dr
becky smathers anton petrov made ethan
siegel made
and so i've compiled a list of those
individuals and their um and their
criticism of uh mr lerner and his big
bang never happened hypothesis and you
and i uh put together a few slides to
guide the discussion and i'll post those
slides if you're listening on uh on
audio podcast forms
you'll miss out on that but i'll put a
link to the to download in the show
notes for this episode um and i'll also
do that in the video text description
for those of you not um subscribed yet
please do subscribe to the channel uh dr
brian keating and so some of the
so let me queue up the
uh the video let me see if i can get
that hopefully people can see this
i will add us as inserts
only uh to not go completely crazy but i
will remove uh the inserts fear not
folks out there so hopefully
folks can see this
online let's look yes i can see this
online so other folks can see it too
okay so
two of us have been talking about this
for uh for some time and uh uh offline
at least the the controversy and why
it's useful to claim um to push back on
claims with uh with respect and uh you
know with without uh with absence of ad
hominem attacks i i have to say i i
don't um appreciate when debates are
held like this now i i'm not engaging uh
mr lerner in a debate i didn't invite
him on this channel he didn't invite me
on his channel
but i think it's more important to uh
respond via this calm you know collected
uh format where he replied via a
powerpoint presentation so let's respond
to it in that format
um so uh that being said let us take a
look at some of the uh classical
motivations for the big bang and this is
just taken from ethan siegel's post um
entitled has jwst disproven the big bang
and really this is just shown we'll come
back to
to dr siegel's objections to mr lerner's
claims at the end uh when you and i also
um present some of our constraints uh
and and criticism of the plasma
cosmology or of the uh non-expanding
universe that he is offering
um we won't uh we'll start off by
talking about support for the big bang
the evidence for the big bang then we'll
move into the jwst findings
and then we'll even touch upon some of
mr lerner's criticisms about the other
so-called pillars of the big bang i've
made some videos recently about that as
well
and we will of course take on the claims
made that definitively the big bang can
be ruled out via classical
constraints and observations such as the
tallman test
so i'll leave this slide up for a few
more seconds but basically there's
abundant evidence for decades that the
big bang model meets and i think it's
wise to quote from jim peebles uh
eminent nobel laureate and
all-around wonderful individual who also
had a huge role in the establishment of
the big bang and the measurement and
interpretation
of the cmb radiation as well
and that was um that was really no uh no
no secret and he's saying uh that in
empirical cosmology which is what we're
trying to do here
there should be a goal not to get
explain every single observation
but instead
to explain the most number of things
with the fewest number of input
assumptions recognizing this is a paper
that he wrote recently put out called
anomalies in cosmology so to mr lerner's
claim that nobody's taking this
seriously or taking any uh criticism of
the big bang or my favorite is when
people accuse me of making my money from
the big bang you know i don't know about
you garen but how much money do we make
from big bang big big big bang very
little it's not like big oil i wish that
would be great
um in fact mr lerner is is uh you know
has every right to raise money for his
uh project which is a fusion project
which he does in his video so that's
fine but we don't get paid there's no
cabal or consortium as as he seems to
imply
so people's talks about by this i mean
empirical evidence that seems likely to
disagree with what is expected from the
previously accepted theories and ideas
an anomaly might prove to be a better to
give us better appreciation of the
predictions of the theory we already
have
and then he goes into
this 26 page long paper which is
phenomenal and i recommend it to all my
students and to even lay people it's
incredibly readable i'll put a link to
it in the show notes later on
um and so he's asking what is the value
of criticism so criticism is to be
valued and appreciated um
truly being obstinate ignoring evidence
to the contrary practicing uh
confirmation bias etc is not a useful or
um or um or expected uh process to get
at quote-unquote truth and i always like
to say we know we know that that things
and signs are not possible to prove we
cannot prove things the way that we
prove you know one plus one equals two
um but we can prove
um beyond a reasonable doubt certain
elements of the theory and so this is
just showing luke unfortunately he's got
a play button over his face um this is
from your your appearance where you guys
went into a construction of a checklist
to get your big bang alternative so i
wonder if you can
talk about
what one does if one is trying to come
up with a big bang alternative
in in your conception what should
somebody do
and maybe as a useful lesson or
teachable moment for people like mr
lerner here are some things that should
be abided by before you claim that
everyone who came before you is wrong
and you are solely correct in possession
of the truth uh uh garen do you want to
say anything about this kind of big bang
alternative checklist
yeah yeah so there's a there's a whole
bunch of points there i think um i think
the phrase that luke and i use when we
talk about this is that you've got to
know your enemy in the sense that you've
got to have a proper picture of what the
landscape looks like so you you can't
really attack a theory with a very
pinpointed sort of oh there's one little
piece here that i find that i i can
fight against
the big bang picture is a is a set of
observations that cover an awful lot of
observations from the last
more than 100 years
and your idea has to have a comment on
all of them and it has to at least match
what the big bang has said with regards
to these points
or
and do better if it wants to supersede
the
um the big bang theory as the the
leading description for how we
understand the universe and this is we
go from something
very simple right from the the obelisk
paradox why is the night sky dark i mean
it it's a very uh deep philosophical
kind of thing to think about the night
sky but if your theory
that you've worked over there suddenly
says that the night sky should be you
know bright and at a temperature of
several thousand degrees you know that
you've already lost
but you've got so you've got to take
your theory and you have to be prepared
for your theory to confront all
observations not just the ones that you
like so yeah that checklist is you've
got to work your way through to at least
get on par with the big bang and then go
beyond if you want to supersede it
yes i think that's a phenomenal entree
into the next point and i should say
that people have accused mr lerner of
you know so-called cherry picking where
you take a um a flaw
a foible if you will in previously
accepted theory or thought
then you
you assail that as being completely
dispositive towards the
conjecture which everything else is
built upon and so with the advent of new
data
i'm showing here
from nasa esa et cetera this is jwst on
the right data same field as max field
and then hst data on the left and i
should point out that i think smax is a
small portion of the hubble deep field
the hubble deep field was established in
a way to get to basically stare at
nothing it wasn't thought that we'd find
evolution of galaxy formation and
structure and therefore invalidate the
big bang nor is jwst i mean if you look
at jwst's science rationale it wasn't to
disprove or to prove the big bang thanks
to big bang incorporated it was to study
the properties and evolution of
structures including exoplanets and
including planets in our solar system so
we have to look at when there's
aspersions being cast at a community
such as a professional community of
astronomers cosmologists astrophysicists
planet hunters exobiologists that the
it is scientifically uh
distasteful to accuse them of having
been guided by themselves of the very
yeah um the very flaw that you may be
guilty of which is cherry-picking
confirmation bias etc so i'm showing
data here now i like to make an analogy
and maybe you know you can correct me if
i'm if i'm wrong or if you don't agree
with it but um if you think back to the
theory of the origin of the moon
uh prior to the apollo moon landings in
1960s uh this was uh hotly contested in
fact it's still not established to the
level of say the pythagorean theorem or
you know fermat's last theorem we can't
prove things in the context of a
of a um of a mathematical uh
sufficiently adequate format to
constitute mathematical proof we can
establish evidence you know for example
yeah as isaac asimov said if you believe
the earth is flat you're wrong
if you believe the earth is spherical
you're wrong
uh if you say that the earth has a
quadrupole distortion you're wrong in
other words we make more and more
distinctions but you're less wrong if
you say the earth is a sphere than if
you say it's flat and you're even less
wrong if you say it has a has a value of
a quadripolar distortion than you are if
you say it's spherical but no one would
throw out the origin of planetary
solar system dynamics based on the
failure of a theory to a match the
platonic ideal of perfection that uh
people like mr lerner and others seem to
require of other people's scientific
theories while completely ignoring the
lacunae in their own theory so this is
one example the origin of the moon hotly
contested still not 100
uh ratified but until the 1960s when we
got physical evidence brought back
hundreds of kilograms from the um
from the
uh moon landing astronauts uh we and
we're going back hopefully very soon to
the moon and get even more information
and perhaps more that was not really
understood maybe the moon was captured
maybe uh uh was formed at the same time
maybe it was an asteroid etc etc and now
we think it's from a giant impact this
thing called thea
et cetera et cetera now it may be that
there's some elements of these other
models that are still correct but we are
converging upon a model and to say that
once we went to the moon that overthrew
our knowledge analogously to what he's
saying about the
about the
jwst data being of higher quality higher
caliber more refined and more precise it
in no way
disparages the big bang model even
though it wasn't designed to measure the
big bag so i don't know if you have any
other analogies uh guarant um that you'd
like to drop on people for how you
refine a model and a departure from its
platonic ideal of perfection is in no
way a condemnation of the underlying
model itself
i don't know garen do you have any
oh yes sorry
a little small glitch yeah you know i
completely agree i think this is
something that people
outside of science don't realize that
that uh it's always building on what
came before and making
more accurate and accurate predictions
about the universe by modifying your
theories and it's always at every stage
you hold up your evidence at that time
to to nature and say you know
are we getting better is our model
description getting better and and so
um you know just because we now have
einstein's generals
oh yeah i lost your audio can you do you
hear me in german
oh yeah i just i lost the last five
seconds
okay i was just saying that um that we
now that we have einstein's general
theory of relativity as a description of
gravity that doesn't mean that we've
completely put newton in the bin
we know the regimes which newton works
in and is accurate in and we don't need
to use relativity but we also know the
places where relativity starts to matter
and that's where we want the more
accurate predictions so it's always
building and always gathering evidence
asking nature how are we doing yeah
exactly um so yeah uh now when we look
at uh the some of the evidence that's
claimed from uh mr lerner's uh second
video which he made this week and kindly
sent to me uh this uh we you can send me
messages by the way on my mailing list
briankeating.com list uh please take
advantage of that um and
the
um
uh the video that he's uh showing here
let's see if this will get to play i
don't know if we'll be able to play it
so in this video and i put a link to it
on the show notes below uh he's talking
about the problems of of tiny galaxies
and smooth discs
so
that brings us to his main
complaint and
an argument against the big bang in
which he published in the
institute for art and ideas news
website and that's a sort of a
philosophy journal in the uk
they host a a festival which um which mr
learner will be appearing at called how
the light gets in in a couple of weeks
in the uk i was invited to it i cannot
make it this time i hope to be there
later in 2023 hopefully um and uh and
i'm quoting from his paper so he says
that what do we find in this uh
and this uh what do they really show and
he says lots of surprises and not
necessarily pleasant ones
one paper and by the way that is first
of all kind of betraying a lack of
knowledge about what scientists are
actually endeavoring to do so to say
something's not pleasant means that you
had an expectation you have confirmation
and some of your happiness is invested
in the
confirmation of your pet theory so i
think that that is again not a genuine
critique of science in fact one could
accuse mr lerner of of essentially
arguing the same way because he has been
making these exact same arguments as i
pointed out in my first video uh two
weeks ago now that uh since 1991 since
his book by the same name the big bang
never happened and that was thoroughly
debunked if you will by professor ned
wright who's a national academy member
member of the kobe team leader of the
wise mission this is eminent cosmologist
at ucla now what he did in that paper
was was comment on some of the uh not
only the toulmin test which we'll
hopefully get to in a minute
but also on the structure formation and
what was happening at that time garen as
you know in the 1990s was the hubble
deep field was coming out and uh and and
this was supposedly uh time for panic
because it showed the galaxies uh could
form say uh 500 million years after the
big bang which according to mr lerner of
course didn't happen so it presented a
great crisis for big bang adherence but
not for him who believes in infinitely
old not expanding static universe
and so in this thing he's portraying
astronomers as deeply investing their
happiness in the uh in the confirmation
of the big bang so and then of course he
famously said that the paper title
begins with the candid exclamation panic
um now of course i already debunked that
that was in the previous video dr becky
debunked that uh that's a playful pun
which that paper that he's referring to
which is called panic at the discs which
is about the preponderance of discs
relative to expectations before jwst
now um that that was also not
coincidentally also some of these
phenomena were evident in the hubble
data which provides a source of of great
you know comfort to those that are uh
wanting to believe in the accuracy of
the web data in other words if you saw
something radically different in other
words you saw there was a disk in hubble
that jwst also saw but it didn't see it
as a disk then you'd start to truly have
some grave concerns i believe in this
case we see some similar structures as i
showed uh in this slide here these
images wherever hubble and could see and
resolve a disk
as these authors went through in this
paper like this disk right here
we see it in uh in in this image by web
as well except we see with much higher
resolution and in fact that should be a
good thing because it would allow you to
trace the rotation curve properties of
the disk et cetera et cetera the authors
of the panic so-called panic paper are
really looking at the morphology how
many of these disks are here now if you
saw this was a disk with web but it
wasn't a disk
in in hubble then you would perhaps
start to question the fact that you see
where hubble had the sensitivity
resolution and wavelength coverage you
see the exact same uh structure and it
was adequate to detect a disk at a given
red shift you see the exact same
structure in web there's absolutely no
tension between them and i think that's
again portraying a a rather
uh large misunderstanding of what the
hubble uh data show versus the web data
so now i'm showing the uh the slide that
you made up the cows are small but the
ones out there are far away
he makes a huge deal
karen about
the
uh the presence of so-called small
galaxies
i wonder if you could talk about that i
have some slides that discuss this as
well
i wonder if you could explain the tolman
test which before you do i cannot resist
chiding mr lerner
for demonstrating
perhaps an intentional
a lack of knowledge of of what redshift
actually is and i'll i'll call that up
while you're uh while you're work while
you explain this this issue of the
so-called
small galaxies uh garen can you explain
what this uh what this means this this
the spirals being uh far away
yeah so so there's a couple of issues
here so
first thing we have to remember
um at the moment from these images all
we have are images of these particular
galaxies
and um we are infer in their distances
so
we we know from their their apparent
colors that we see we can sort of work
out where they are in particular regis
range but we do not know specifically
where everything is and to to
essentially
nail down the distances we've got to go
and get spectra right we've got to get
the spectra of these galaxies so we can
measure the red shifts and that will
tell us more precisely
where these objects are so at the moment
we see in these these particular disks
and we're trying to work out where they
are because that because you need that
to infer what their actual sizes are and
we don't really know there's a there's a
significant uncertainty in there and if
i could imagine that in the future when
we get more accurate data there will be
you know it would be uh that some of
them are a little bit closer some are a
bit further away
but it won't be until that point that we
will really know the distribution of
where these disks are
because all we have is what's this
picture on the sky and we need more
information to do those kinds of
measurements
now
yeah now one of the key things that i
mean i think a lot of the argument
that's been presented here is over the
angular size of objects on the sky right
so this is
the one of the key cornerstones of the
the argument in eric paper etc is that
in his static universe then you have
this obvious thing that happens as you
take objects further away they will look
smaller and smaller whereas in an
expanded universe the relationship
between the redshift which we infer as
as a as a distance and the angular size
of an object becomes much more
complicated because the universe has
expanded between the time that the light
has left from the object to here
so we we just have to be very very
careful with just the raw images that we
have about working out exactly what the
size of these objects are but we do know
that for a lot of the objects we see if
the expanding model is right and these
objects are in the redshift range that
we're referring they were relatively
small and relatively bright
which is
what we expect over no in a in a very
hand wavy kind of way in our pictures of
how galaxies form and evolve right we i
i we spoke about this when i was in
graduate school back in the 1990s that
you know galaxies form hierarchically
they start off small and they get bigger
and bigger and bigger and we also know
that the rate of star formation has not
been the same over the 14 billion years
and the universe was much more vigorous
when it was younger
driven by the mergers
a lot a lot of it driven by the mergers
that again um that um eric was sort of
um against
as galaxies have built up over time and
we've got these beautiful charts of the
history of star formation we know that
the vast majority of stars have already
been made and all this kind of stuff so
we we we know that
the past was a different country right
things were done differently there beca
because the universe was evolving in a
different way so the fact that there was
their small galaxies seen in jwt is is
not not uh not
what am i trying to say it doesn't
conflict with the overall picture that
we have that galaxy start off small and
grow larger
right in fact you know if you you
wouldn't have to ask questions about the
evolution in a static universe at all
and the age of a static universe or
purported age of a why is there any
evolution not to mention uh the absence
of creation of uh of of of matter that's
required to
counteract the collapse of a of a uh
purely matter filled universe as
purported in uh mr lerner's
work uh which brings me to another
effect um and and i have to point out as
i said you know he's talking about this
here this is his what he claims in his
most recent video is the definition of
redshift now i don't know about you
uh
karen or what you teach your students i
don't start by teaching the tolman test
as uh the definition from which you can
extract the redshift what we call the
redshift as the ratio as defined in his
equation here so i think for a for a
layperson someone who's not an expert
this might be very convincing but to an
astronomer this just looks very
unprofessional eric and i would say that
this uh is intentional cherry-picking uh
of you know if you imagine like what
does it mean to say the size of a galaxy
these things are not like standard
rulers that exist and even if they do to
the extent that they have some
large number he makes this big deal
these things that he calls mighty mouse
galaxies etcetera again a terminology
that's not professionally used or
accepted
this as somehow dispositive that the big
bang is wrong again if you look back on
this image
i'll even take it from his our own
article there we go so there are many
different types and sizes of galaxies by
the way some of the gravitational
lensing that's exhibited here is a
direct consequence of einstein's theory
of general relativity which presupposes
the expansion of the universe is driven
by a universe with composition according
to ordinary matter alone or radiation
alone would be sufficient to cause it to
either expand or contract but not stay
static and of course that was the reason
einstein came up with this famous fudge
factor apocryphally called his biggest
blunder
mr lerner dismisses that apparently
entirely although i don't know how in
his plasma cosmology can explain
gravitational lensing which is
concomitant with and maybe even a lesser
um of lesser relevance for his arguments
than the actual expansion itself and he
as i'll show later he has no explanation
for the expansion which he admits he
admits he has no explanation for the
redshift and what he's doing is using
these measurements supposedly to prove
that the universe is not indeed
expanding
another classic i just
yeah just add a little point so i i i
think i mentioned this a little bit
later on in my size so gravitational
lenses which is an area i've worked in a
lot i mean
that brings together so many aspects of
uh einstein's general relativity right
the deflection of light and the
cosmological expansion so you need to
use angular angular diameter distances
to work out lens in
and they all come together right so it's
if you start to sort of say oh i don't
trust the angular diameter distances but
i'll keep the the gravitational lens in
part it doesn't work anymore the
relationship between red shifts and
sizes doesn't work so it
it fits together very very neatly and so
if you want to say that
lensing
you i want to play around and do
something else what you're doing is
you're you're multiplying up those
extra bits and pieces that you're adding
to your theory to get things to work and
that is a path that is very bad for
theories
can i can i just do a little historical
aside here yeah of course
so
what this reminds me of uh is uh fred
hoyle and steady state and and fred
hoyle is a is a hero of mine i i read
lots of his work i like his stuff but of
course he got into his particular right
on his steady state universe
and what was happening as uh you know
the steady state was proposed in the 40s
and as more and more evidence came in
like from the existence of the cmb the
evolution of galaxies etc
he had to jerry rig
new little pieces everywhere to try and
stay on par with the big bang theory and
so his cmb was created by iron whiskers
aligned by magnetic fields etc and the
entire complexity of his cosmological
model just exploded just exploded
whereas the the standard big bang
basically is the same equations written
down in the 1920s that we used today
that's right so this yeah this is this
multiplication of i i will just insert
another thing here to describe this
thing is not the way that a good theory
develops yeah
and when you look at so no uh so george
grubbs is uh is saying let's stick to
the objective uh truth here i'll put
george up uh let's stick to objective
analysis so one of my listeners by the
way you can listen and you can
send me feedback on my channel dr brian
keating on youtube i take comments and
questions on on
twitter as well
um no george we can't stick to the
analysis of the data it's not casting
aspersions to use his own flaws and his
reasoning logic and the accusations that
he's making again the truth that these
papers don't report this is what he's
saying that we are not reporting the
truth science is censoring him he is
casting aspersions himself so unless you
want to be totally hypocritical george
you open yourself up when you ascribe
motivations to a class of professionals
not individuals saying you know i'm not
saying eric's a bad person he's evil
he's no i'm saying here are the flaws in
his analysis here's another one he
purports to be this an expert maybe
self-trained maybe not um but uh and and
that's fine you can be self-trained uh
but um uh when i talk about the the
critics of the disagreements with the
status quo i just reported from a nobel
prize winner jim peebles it wasn't a
paper about anomalies in the big bang
you can't get more you know conventional
than someone who's won the nobel prize
uh then than that so i think i think
you're missing the point um uh but but
thanks for your comment here so anything
that he puts in his written work or his
published work or his youtube is fair
game here's another example he defines
here a parsec as being three light years
now if i want to be you know cherry pick
and say he doesn't understand the very
definition of the first rung in the
distance ladder effectively the first on
the cosmological distance ladder which
would be used to establish a plot of
redshift versus distance and so he sets
up a straw man which is very convincing
to those of you who are laypeople he
gets the math wrong here he doesn't
understand the definition of a parsec
and
that's incomplete he mischaracterized
the definition of redshift to suit a
purpose to claim that there's
disagreement and invalidity of the big
bang model which is not the common
definition of redshift which is
stretching wavelength due to the doppler
shift which we've known about for 300
years uh it happens for light as well as
it happens for sound
and this has been known as i said for
hundreds of years so for him to say that
that's the definition astronomers use
again go back to this image of mr
lerner's quoting you know from from nasa
um do these gal what's the size of these
galaxies uh assume the ones that are the
same color are roughly at the same
distance there's huge variation in their
sizes so not accounting for any form of
evolution and just saying they're all
standard rulers effectively and then
saying that's the tolman test and that's
the definition of redshift astronomers
don't know what they're doing i think is
is not a professionally acceptable way
to treat these data then he's got this
paper from 2018 he claims that he's been
censored you know people are hiding the
truth um here's the actual definition i
provided below angular size relation i'm
covering it up here i'll uncover it
there it is so there's the actual
angular size redshift distance
relationship in a non-expanding universe
you would expect to see as the diagonal
lines in the uh and the upper right plot
show in a non-expanding universe
you would expect to see your steady
state universe this slowly monotonically
decreasing size of galaxies as you move
farther and farther away if indeed they
had some uniform distance but notice the
plot this is a professional plot this is
from a textbook on the bottom similar
data
they don't agree first of all with the
static steady state universe second of
all they have error bars and what
troubles me about what mr lerner seems
to do there's never any error bars
associated he's got this miraculous fit
to a straight line a constant angular
amine radius of galaxies no error bars
ascribed to it now how this got
published in monthly notices um you know
is is sort of a question i wasn't the
referee of it
but it shows two things it shows that
he's not following professional
standards there's nothing about being a
critic of the big bang that precludes
you from using error bars right current
i mean
anybody can use it and there are error
bars in it and the sign of a good
scientist i tell my students is not what
you know that you know it's how you
accurately characterize what you know
you don't know and here on the right a
professional astronomer showing that
there is a minimum galaxy size which you
do not expect in a steady state static
model like mr lerner's um and he's just
going on saying no this isn't true and
ignoring the data i don't know do you
have a comment on on this garrett
well um yeah yeah i sort of agree i i
did read the the paper from uh 20
uh 2018. okay it yeah so this this
entire question of the size of galaxies
and doing this particular test we we
know if the universe was just filled
with
one meter rulers scattered throughout
then cosmology would be easy right if we
if we if we have did have a real
standard ruler but the big problem is is
that
galaxies are like people right and and
they're more diverse than people because
they come from being really tiny to
really really big and when you construct
a sample of galaxies and say what is the
size of these galaxies there are biases
in you know what can you telescope
observe
what sample of galaxies do you have in
there are they are they clustered
together or these galaxies out on their
own because their sizes are different
again
so it's a it's a it's actually a very
complicated
experiment to do because you've got to
work out right
am i really dealing with the same
objects
if i'm going to declare that these
things have the same size that's right
and
it's it's it's it's well
i i haven't followed the the growth of
the
cosmological distance ladder and
cosmological tests these are all
difficult tests because the universe has
changed over time right the universe a
billion years ago five billion years ago
is not the same as the universe today
and so we cannot compare apples here to
origins there very easily right and you
say accurately um uh and and properly
that the uh the big bang theory was
never created nor was it intended um nor
does it really include the growth or
structure formation of galaxies and
individual properties of individual
galaxies whether they're disk or
irregular
or spheroidal
and part of the reason that jwst is a
motivated for it's it's uh it's you know
technological and scientific
capabilities but b was not designed to
do cosmology that's my realm and
actually mr lerner undoes some of his
credibility in a different fashion by
saying that if the big bang were true
we'd expect to find a
an epoch at which there were no galaxies
um and in fact we do and it's called the
epoch of recombination and the formation
of the cosmic microwave background so
how does he deal with that he's not he's
not unintelligent he has another theory
for the uh evolution and for the um
appearance of the cosmic microwave
background it's a so-called monopole he
has zero um
things to say about its anisotropy its
polarization or its other properties
which have been studied to you know many
many decimal places in just the last 20
years
and again this is all sort of not was
not maybe as precisely understood when
he wrote his book
and uh in 1991 but since then there's
been tremendous growth of our knowledge
and improvement in technology and he
still has not updated his original
hypotheses explanation for the cmb etc
etc next you talk about um
galaxy evolution and what the general
properties of galaxies should be can you
say something briefly about this um what
would we expect
well so i mean i think we have this
overall expectation that galaxy the
universe started relatively small smooth
and galaxies grew so they were smaller
and they're getting larger so we have
that overall picture but what what is
what's really needed is the details this
is part of why hst is looking at these
most distant galaxies is because that
initial stage of galaxy formation
it's complicated and it's complicated
because there's an interplay between
the dark matter which is providing the
gravitational sort of framework for the
universe and the the baryons the gas the
atoms and
but that gas physics or gastrophysics as
i've written there that is very
complicated right
even understanding it in our own milky
way right because what we've got is a
galaxy which is a hundred thousand light
years from side to side and we have gas
doing stuff on the scale of individual
stars and we're trying to encompass all
of that and imagine that in a universe
where there's an awful lot going on
so
part of the reason that we've got these
jwst images is so we can work out what
is going on in the early universe to to
tie it to the evolution of galaxies over
all of cosmic time yes and so there's a
there's a big uncertainty there and i'm
not surprised that our models of the
initial stages of galaxy evolution
don't really match what we see in the
telescopes they're not radically wrong
right but there are definitely a few
issues that we will need to sort out and
you probably uh you know this brian that
give the the guys with super computers a
little bit of time and everything will
be perfectly explained anyway because
they will just say oh what we needed to
do was this efficiency of star formation
there and giant stars do this and voila
we get the universe as seen by jwst
right
and uh quoting more from the so-called
panic paper um
and uh and so forth i think this is
instructional to show let me swap us
back up sorry
let me go back to our shot together and
with the um so this is from the panic so
called panic paper uh where mr lerner
claims
galaxy structure and morphology are key
aspects for understanding galaxy
evolution and will be a key measurement
that jwst will make throughout its
lifetime following the first service
mission to hubble galaxies started to
have their structure revealed in the mid
90s
and galaxy distances became more
peculiar and irregular than local cure
doesn't mean it doesn't fit in it's just
the astronomer name for certain
appearances of different galaxies then
they have this
hubble sequence so called hubble
sequence when rich just became available
first with the hubble deep field it was
clear so this is when the hubble deep
field is 30 years ago that galaxy
structures evolved strongly and
systematically with redshift such that
peculiar galaxies dominate the
population z greater than two and a half
so he's talking about there being this
panic because we didn't expect this with
jwst has revealed the shocking new
information their paper which he didn't
apparently read thoroughly uh shows that
jwc not only confirmed some of the
observations as i showed you visually
but it also agrees and confirms uh the
appearance of phenomena that that hubble
saw and there's regions of overlap where
they agree here on spheroidals there's
some um versus redshift we look at error
bars including error bars there is uh
there there is agreement this is hubble
versus hst this is exactly what the
panic the
paper by ferrari at all are talking
about so they're saying that there is
some more evolution
there is nothing in these data that
cause have anything to say about the
origin of the formation of the light
elements which is what we astronomers
and cosmologists are referring to when
we talk about the quantitative aspects
of the big bang there's nothing
quantitative
relative to the big bang there's
something quantitative to the
measurement the data
of galaxies but not about the underlying
theory in the background expansion of
space time which we call the big bang
yeah go ahead i think i i think i noted
on the previous slide i mean if if if
the big bang was in in in fear every
time a galaxy ma galaxy evolution model
doesn't work you'd be
terrified all the time because the as i
said these things are complicated and
more information comes in you have to
rework your models etc uh it's just part
of how it goes that's right
so uh and that's uh that's a good thing
in fact one of the things that he quoted
and uh
and got you know these people to call
him names which again i'm not calling
him any names uh you know to those like
george that are uh particularly
sensitive to any any sort of criticism
of the ideas we're not criticizing the
human we're criticizing these ideas and
we can also criticize the tactics and
techniques that are used if you have a
viral post in which you accuse
astronomers of
acting intellectually dishonestly
because they are being
contradicting the truth that these
papers are willing to hide as he says
here another thing that he said is
allison kirkpatrick who is a
a phenomenally successful
professor at kansas university
university of kansas rather
he said in the second point this is
a quote from allison professor
kirkpatrick and she says right now i
find myself lying awake at three in the
morning and wondering if everything i've
done is wrong and then this is a quote
from jack ryan i think his article in
cnet uh this cherry pick quote isn't in
direct reference to the big bang theory
well rather kirkpatrick is reckoning
um with the first data coming back to
jwc about the early evolution of the
universe in particular it's the galaxies
that she's talking about it's true there
are some puzzles for astronomers so far
they aren't rewriting the beginning of
the universe to do so she has stated uh
that that her quotes are misused by mr
lerner and changed her twitter name to
allison the big bang happened
kirkpatrick so there's a picture of her
twitter profile so into my knowledge he
hasn't apologized for taking that out of
context again it's cherry picked is it
is it trying to get headlines is that
unfair of him um you know it shouldn't
should he not be held to the same
standard that others are asking uh him
to be held into i think it's only fair
um so uh the last couple of quotes i
just want to show you how far back does
this go with mr lerner well it goes back
pretty far this is from 2003 i talked
about this in my first video i'll have a
link to it in the video description
uh this is from professor ned wright an
eminent incredibly accomplished
cosmologist uh astrophysicist um a
professor at mit and ucla
talks about the errors going back
with
the formation evolution of structures
he's claiming that the absence of the
need for dark matter is a flaw and that
the cmb is too perfect to be a black
body all these have been completely
superseded completely shown demonstrate
demonstrably to be completely incorrect
there's 400 sigma agreement that the cmb
is a blackbody and that there are
fluctuations in the background intensity
so-called anisotropy which is part of
what i study and polarization that are
completely consistent with not only the
big bang but with the cold dark matter
paradigm in fact some of the strongest
evidence we have for the big bang for
dark matter comes from the uh the
existence of fluctuations in the cosmic
microwave background a subject that mr
lerner is completely mute upon he
doesn't have any explanation for why
there's polarization of the cmb
uh and i guess that shouldn't be
surprising again he doesn't have an
explanation for redshift
he doesn't believe that redshift takes
place so he has to resort to things like
tired light interaction with with
matter particles ordinary matter
particles doesn't believe in that uh so
let's conclude in the last ten minutes
um i i took you know only one question i
will we both have to leave uh in ten
minutes and i think we've uh done uh
yeoman's work if i don't
tip my hat to us
karen um here's ethan siegel's uh
general um
you know kind of criticism
of the model that mr lerner has so some
of my audience will say things oh you
shouldn't criticize him just the big
bang has all these flaws in it well
we've pointed out the details and
actually we glossed over some of the
glaring successes of the big bang which
which uh mr lerner uh has no explanation
for the abundance of these elements
except for
things that were ruled out in 2003 by
ned wright and you can look those up
there he has no explanation for the
formation of the light elements um and
uh and that hasn't been debunked by by
uh by professor ned wright
but let's get to ethan's uh so so ethan
is now commenting on uh this is dr ethan
siegel who runs a very popular um uh
outreach and um he is a trained
astrophysicist so uh dr siegel talks
about things are really bad for plasma
cosmology uh advocates fast if they dare
to genuinely confront their ideas with
observations of the universe
so it doesn't oscillate we didn't talk
about oscillatory universes
in most conceptions mr lerner the
oscillatory period and his models are
extremely long maybe even infinitely
long
so i didn't spend too much time in that
he also is talking about for decades
including in the article that is the
errors found in his book by professor
ned wright he is talking about these
large transverse velocities uh he talks
about those that there should be uh
these should be prevalent in the plasma
cosmology they don't exist we don't see
it it would also lead to very large
scale effects in the polarization of the
microwave background that i'm an expert
in study we don't see any evidence for
that there's strong constraints to rule
it out completely based on this now he
apparently according to ned wright i
don't know if you knew this garrett but
but he disavowed his association with
hannes alvin's plasma cosmology uh uh
before but it sounds like he's
resurrected it
okay no i i hadn't heard that yeah and
he talks about the cosmic web that
performs this is dr siegel uh forms some
of the best evidence possible for the
universe
in his article he goes over the
simulations and he talks about the cmb
the background radiation can either come
from a series of hot objects which is
what mr lerner at least alvin had
claimed um as the oral reflected
starlight and you mentioned this earlier
it can't be whiskers polarized whiskers
those will be seen very easily by cmb we
don't see it this last observation was
enough to falsify alfin's idea more than
a year before he even proposed that the
plasma cosmology was literally dead on
arrival so that's ethan
i have a list of other problems as i've
already said there's no explanation of
cnb polarization no explanation of c and
b anisotropy uh again this is the nobel
prize in in 2006.
no explanation of blue shifts and
transverse velocities and no explanation
of redshift he does he says all
processes can be explained by lab tested
physics this is his slide you can see mr
learner in the upper right um i'll move
it over hopefully you can see it um and
uh
there he is
uh
except for the hubble process so he's
saying everything can be explained or
tested at least or explained he's saying
he can explain all the cosmic so-called
cosmic processes that otherwise seem to
indicate expansion they can all be
explained except for the hubble process
that's a pretty big exception
that's literally the foundational pillar
on which the uh expanding universe is
predicated by people who didn't want to
believe in it like even lemaitre didn't
want to believe in it and actually
who mr lerner supports purportedly or
did
he hated the idea because it seemed to
apply a biblical
uh congruence between the biblical
genesis 1 1 narrative so mr alfine or dr
alvain nobel laureate he was against the
big bang on on extra scientific
non-scientific a scientific um
agenda-driven ideas um so but anyway he
mr lerner cannot explain the most the
key ingredient in all of uh cosmology
which is that galaxies every galaxy with
the exception of 10 or 20 handful of
local ones all seem to be expected
that's a pretty big gap wouldn't you say
guarant
yeah yeah
again it's taken with the totality of
the evidence right again the the
the framework for cosmology is
relatively simple the ingredients that
you add for big bang nuclear synthesis
etc again relatively straightforward and
you explain a whole wealth
of observations
and having to add all these other little
bits and pieces to try and explain cmb
over here or you know galaxy evolution
over there
it's
it's not good for theories right it's
multiplying the factors that
unnecessarily yeah so
in in reality we need the scales of
justice for theories and we need to
weigh them based on how well they
explain their evidence and
you know and the big bang does very very
well which is why it's hard to unseat
that's right not because we not because
we love it
lots of people hate it but it it works
that's the point
so um the last thing i want to comment
that he doesn't have a plausible
explanation for abundances and yet his
adherents his proponents et cetera
including people in the chat room are
saying well okay you've explained you
know the the support for jbst
observations that aren't inconsistent
with the big bang you've explained that
the properties of galaxies are
consistent between hubble and wbst where
there is sufficient technological
overlap and wavelength and sensitivity
and angular resolution
and so that would be a huge hurdle that
the big bang model if you like to
whatever extent it does make predictions
about evolution or structure formation
could have failed but did not
um we we know that mr learn doesn't have
an explanation for abundances but he's
pointed out that astronomers don't
understand the lithium problem this i
get a lot a lot of this stuff lithium
problem is the key thing
we're hanging our hat now on this okay
so here's abundances here the elemental
abundance is measured by
multiple dozens of different teams with
different telescopic tools ranging from
the early part of the evolution of the
universe using the cosmic microwave
background that i study and the planck
satellite
studied um and predictions and
observations from astronomers looking at
stars in our galaxy and even our own sun
and these are for four or five of the
lightest elements on the periodic table
and they're isotopes so this is showing
primordial helium abundance helium-4
there's another
isotope of helium called helium-3 we
actually use that to cool down our
detectors to sub-kelvin temperatures
deuterium which is heavy hydrogen i'll
have a video by the way on my channel
about you'll see me drinking
deuterium oxide which is heavy water and
see if i live or not
and then there's lithium
so in uh and there's also hydrogen
which is not shown on here this is
relative to hydrogen so for hydrogen
helium isotope of helium of hydrogen and
isotope of helium four different uh
isotopes or elemental abundances four of
them agree and you can't even see the
error bars now the one that's known the
worst with the bigger green band sort of
at the bottom is lithium-7 and it is
true that the planck value if you will
differs from the
stellar abundances and observations by
several sigma so this is you know a few
parts in a thousand chance of being a
statistical fluke it could be real but
the amount of information that first of
all in the three and four including
hydrogen and isotopic hydrogen
ii
that those preponderance the proponents
of evidence is that we have an exquisite
understanding
from multiple evidence avenues looking
at the sun to looking at the cosmic
microwave background a difference in
time of 13.8 billion years difference in
scale of 10 to the 20th power this is
incredible and we should be proud of it
and mr lerner is pointing cherry picking
as some have called it the one value
which is discrepant but the reasons for
its discrepancy
could be manifold and related to
deficiencies lacuna and observational
astronomy having zero
zero absolutely to do with cosmology
karen do you have anything to say about
these abundances and whether this causes
uh
you any loss of sleep or panic
no no so again i think a lot about the
lithium difference but lithium is a
fragile element and we don't understand
all the pathways that it could be
processed through stars and multiple
generations of stars
so maybe this is telling us more about
our lack of understanding of stellar
revolution than it is of the production
of heat lithium in the big bang that's
right but you know lots of people lots
of people are thinking about this and
when the answer's there we'll all go oh
yeah okay that makes sense yeah
that's right uh and the last thing i
want to say is you know he also talks
about the hubble crisis the hubble
tension i too would like people to stop
using the term you know crisis and
hubble tensions and so forth but but in
reality
we understand from phenomena measured at
early times 370 000 years after the big
bang we have an observation of the
expansion rate a prediction with the
expansion rate should be 13.8 billion
years later and it agrees to within 10
percent
of the value measured by local objects
in the expanding universe which mr
lerner has no explanation for but for
the redshift distance relationship over
a variety of different stars and
different stellar objects from globular
clusters tip of the red giant branch
stars
type 2
type 1a supernovae and from cepheid
variables going out over a whole host of
ranges and scale from mega parsecs to
gigaparsex all the way back to the big
bang
so late formation early formation
zero explanation in mr lerner's model
complete agreement to the ten percent
level and even jim people says that is
even though it's an anomaly in other
words these two different methods
disagree at the 10 level it's a stunning
triumph perhaps one of the most
confidence inspiring ideas and
measurements ever made and that's what
we do as scientists right guarant we are
observational and we are driven by
empirical
and epistemologically humble and having
humility and i think we expect that from
critics as well it's not that we don't
like criticism we welcome it sometimes
as nobel laureate jim people says it
provides you some information avenue to
further refine and build up credulity
and confidence in your model professor
lewis i want to thank you so much for
joining us today um i know we both have
to run and i think it was great uh keep
the comments coming i have a link to
more information i'll put a link to my
previous videos and you can check out mr
lerner's videos and i'm sure mr lerner
if you're listening you'll have some
response but i don't find debate
particularly
valuable in the sense that
there's nothing that he can't say live
that he can't say um you know on a uh on
a channel and he actually is going to be
debating uh professor uh priya naraya
um at uh at this how the light gets in
festival so she is even more capable
than than than i am at least i won't
speak for professor lewis um defending
the big bang or at least
uh providing the same argument so look
for that video i'm sure that'll be up at
some point and uh we're in capable hands
and we welcome constructive criticism
but i think ascribing and not being
apologetic and properly
humble in your approach is not the best
uh the best approach anyway garrett
thank you so much have a great rest of
your day i'll put some links and videos
in the slides up as well thanks
everybody
thanks bye bye